how'd you like your bit with the the
eagle taking off your eyebrows did you
like how that came out on camera it's so
hard to not react on a phantom camera
like with my eyes all right yeah
camera you're like don't you i'm not
gonna flinch or anything no you could
try so hard to not flinch but that
really be on your control but then after
it pulls away and you're like
so funny in real life it was
so rad too it's just so cartoonish and
looking back on the podcast that's why
you had the bandana on all those videos
people are always like why is this guy
wearing a bandana because i was right in
the middle of filming and then you had
that little bandanna you look like jeff
what was his name love jeff love the guy
from tiger king yeah we kept calling you
jeff love
yeah
yeah steve lowe steve
yeah
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude